draußen sind 15 grad und sonne und ich
sind ihre kinder spielen videospiele was
ist falsch in meinem leben meine damen
und herren wir befinden uns ja heute auf
der website
keine ahnung wie heißt auf jeden fall
gibt es auf dieser webseite menge
spieler deswegen würde ich sagen spielen
wir halt ein paar spielen
ich weiß nicht was man bei diesem spiel
machen muss aber ich glaube man muss
diesen teilen erreichen also wir können
hier so drücken
butt wollte objects freinet gutes game
is meant to be played using mobile die
war ja wie sieht mein brecht aus wie
mobile device geht also ich gehe jetzt
mal so ein bisschen nach links weil der
ist ja gerade auf der rechten seite
jetzt gehe ich hier hin jetzt muss ich
mich kurz gucken genau jetzt warte ich
wieder so ein bisschen abgenutzt ist er
wieder da ist wie das ganze sogar ein
bisschen schneller view jetzt gehen wir
auf die linke seite
jetzt kommt er nämlich außer media wie
sollen menschen so schnell reagieren
maus challenge ich weiß nicht was
hierbei genau auf geht aber wir kriegen
einfach mal auf start
das ist level 1 müssen nämlich in das
grüne jetzt steht ihr nämlich gott
ich muss immer vom grünen ins rote ich
mach mal sicherheitshalber eben ein ton
aus weil ich angst habe dass das von
james kerr kommt aber keine sorge
freunde falls seine chance gekommen
werde ich euch auf jeden fall waren
[ __ ] ich weiß nicht ob er denkt
dass dieses spiel hier wirklich schwer
ist aber es ist nicht
schon mit dem engen hier vorne durch den
darm trakt dieses schwarzen etwas hier
vier vorderen hier vorne rom ich hier
das ist ja wiener hafen oder dass man
hier halt nach oben fährt dann was
dachte sich dieser mensch dabei dieses
level zu machen weil ich meine das ist
halt echt 0 schwierig ich bin jetzt hier
vorne drin jetzt kann ich hier vorne um
hier an der seite guck mal wie schnell
ich das ja auch mache ich weiß nicht ob
ich einfach eine gute fingerfertigkeit
hallo
was für game auf waren auch über roding
little train dress up
ich habe später beim finger was hier für
pd game ist aber wir kriegen einfach mal
auf play sehen hier ist eine lokomotive
und wir können das spiel besteht daraus
dass wir uns in lokomotiven
zusammenstellen können ein paar sekunden
später ich finde dass das hier auf jeden
fall ein recht ähnliches design ist das
heißt wir kriegen jetzt einfach mal hier
auf den fall sehen jetzt die lokomotive
fährt hier vor das ist wirklich perfekt
animiert haben jetzt steht sie hier und
kann ich noch das war das spiel meines
damen und herren cajun keks dass jetzt
das cover von dem game das heißt wir
kriegen einfach mal auf play sehen schon
wir haben hier sachen herumliegen es ist
einfach candy crash für arme jetzt kann
ich das hier irgendwie runterziehen dann
sind die beiden hier weg jetzt kann ich
das hier unterziehen dann sind die weg
das hier kann nicht runterziehen die
sind automatische weg hier vorne oben
dann ziehe ich jetzt hier vorne dann
haben wir hier wieder anteile dann kann
ich das direkt wieder umziehen dann
haben wir da wieder was dieses spiel
bekommt von mir auf jeden fall der in
der woche klickten bei diesem spiel muss
man anscheinend irgendwie hier
draufklicken damit man
das ist nicht deren scheiß ernst hier
steht jetzt yuan das heißt ich kriege
noch mal das war's das war's warum musst
dich dafür zu beginn 92 mb herunterladen
money clicker also wir haben hier einen
träumen können draufklicken dann
bekommen wir wollen das heißt wir können
die ganze zeit drauf klicken und das
öfter wir drauflegen desto mehr calls
bekommen wir das heißt wir das ist das
ist dass freunde diese website
beinhaltet die besten games die ich je
gesehen habe an alle leute unter euch
die sich öfters meine videos anschauen
soll ja eventuell ab und zu mal
vorkommen da hinten hängen eigentlich
meine pizza die ich vor einigen monaten
raus gebracht habe die habe ich
abgenommen weil wir arbeiten gerade an
einer zweiten pizza und die wird es aber
freunde sorgen
das einzige was ich verschiebt ist die
seite a ha freunde so wir können jetzt
matthew hier so ein bisschen bewegen
laufen jetzt mal hier links auf die tür
zum laufen jetzt mal hier die treppe
runter das heißt matthäus jetzt hier
unten da hat es ein geschenk hier ist ja
präsent sein also wir haben jetzt hier
in d o bekommen könnten einfach mal
drauf klicken das war's
game and into the sea klickt man einfach
auf und sehen wir sind dieser blaue
punkt müssen vielleicht mit denen ja
genau wir müssen mit den pfeiltasten
hier hoch müssen hier rechts rüber und
ja danke auch für das spieldorf falls
sie nicht so gut englisch könnte und
jetzt nicht eventuell wisst was doors
auf deutsch heißt das heißt ganz einfach
[Musik]
ja das spiel das abgestürzt samples best
games ever
wir kriegen hier auch einfach mal of
play the one day also eines tages meine
damen und herren sam bros
übrigens ist keine ahnung war es hieß
wir sollen ruhig sein und die dings
drücken also
ich will sollte man den
nice
auch gut
auch sehr schön auch gut der gefällt mir
wirklich sehr gut aber der hier der der
der ist auch mega gut
aber wieder das komplette spiel wir
hatten in scheiß keyboard mit rübsam
drauf also freunde ich kann euch diese
website wirklich nur wärmstens empfehlen
[Musik]